welcome back to the Ingram angle live
from London it's 3:50 a.m. here and this
marks the 75th anniversary of the d-day
invasion on Thursday and will be in
Normandy commemorating that anniversary
and remembering the veterans living in
dead who saved Europe and the world Fox
News contributor Raymond Arroyo will
also with be with me Raymond you've been
talking to some of these World War two
veterans would you find Laura before we
left the United States in New Orleans I
spoke with Ben Martinez he signed up to
serve in World War two he was 17 years
old and though he served in Italy we
talked about how d-day led to the end of
the war and what that meant to him watch
[Music]
I wanted to get him right away at Pearl
hall but I was advised not to I had five
months to go to get a degree in pharmacy
and the saying
did everybody forget your degree first
and then it was so I'm listening May of
a party to got our mayor 46 Ben Martinez
served in the Italian campaign as a
medic
he and his team traversed the Italian
Alps while a donkey carried their
supplies he still remembers the day he
received word that the war was over I
remember very distinctly when we were at
a little town called our bow and word we
were loaded loaded up the Mules who were
already in the Alps but we're gonna go
up a higher and we were loading up the
mules when word came down that the war
was over and it's just complete silence
nobody talked to anybody I think they
all had their own thing going on their
mind when I when I came to more or less
the first thing I did I went to see the
man who had been loading up the mules
and I think I started crying
it's over you guys won't have to do what
you did before it's over Ben Martinez
came home in the summer of 1945 today at
nearly a hundred he volunteers two days
a week at the National World War two
Museum in New Orleans
sharing with later generations the
firsthand stories that only he can tell
and remembering those who were never
able to tell their stories
and Laura that is what we will be doing
this week telling the stories of these
civilian heroes who truly save the world
as we know it their willingness to
sacrifice their commitment to the shared
cause is something we've lost in
something I hope will remind now and
these people are the ones we know these
stories they're still so compelling data
here but the young people I hope we're
going to take the most out of this week
of commemoration and memories are not
many of these veterans left this will be
the last major anniversary celebrate I
remember in Reagan in 1984 did the
famous scene of the boys on the took the
clip and tomorrow we're gonna be out in
the streets with the protesters well
today the protesters were a little thin
with the picture we'll put it up if we
have at the time there were only handful
outside of the two bucket we're not the
protesters outside of Buckingham Palace
are the two protesters it was very thin
crowd tomorrow they expect thousands in
Trafalgar Square
we'll see what turns up but they are
here to protest the president will be
covering it all and I hear some
supporters are coming to hmm I'm
bringing my straw in case any milkshakes
are thrown strawberry please